you see what happens Larry see what  happens when you find a stranger in the  Alps where'd you get that beauty scar  tough guy eatin pineapple ak-47 the very  best day is when you absolutely  positively got to kill every mother's  father in the room accept no substitutes  that's bullcrap me the keys you fairy  godmother watch what ain't no country I  heard of there's big industry q3q Sam  Rothstein thank you used to call the old  man funny names iron but boner once I  even call him airhead this found like a  great big chicken just waiting to be  plucked number one I remember how often  a Steve masturbate there was a lot you  are gonna be a bad mother crusher  you because mr. Falcon  I have had it with these monkey fighting  snakes on this Monday to Friday play  everybody strapped in  about the open freaking window  [Music]